foreign
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
he's on tour dude he is on tour we moved
the Jacksonville and the Lakeland uh
dates
um to January
uh so I'm sorry about that for people
that were coming to see me
um this week in uh in Jacksonville but I
will be there in uh Lakeland and Jack
Lakeland Daytona now I added January
26th Lakeland January 27th Daytona
January 28th Jacksonville Florida
um and before that I'll be in San Diego
uh uh on the weekend of the seventh so
go get your tickets there
um Brea California I'm doing a club some
Club dates uh and then uh I'm doing a
theater in Seattle Washington that
filled up so we added another show
McCall Hall
crystallia.com January 22nd that's on a
Sunday come out and have a nice Sunday
evening with your boy you know a nice
Sunday evening and then San Antonio
February 3rd Sugarland Texas February
4th New Orleans February 5th and then
we're going to February 17th we're doing
Providence Rhode Island and then New
York New York Start Spreading the News
in New York New York February 18th two
shows at the Beacon Theater and then
Chicago Illinois uh Kansas City
Springfield Missouri look at all these
Tulsa Oklahoma just get a load of this
[__] okay this is how a touring this is
how it goes Midland Texas Austin Texas
Minneapolis Columbus Ohio Cincinnati
Boise it keeps going so go to
crystallia.com and get your tickets
there's also other ones that have been
added I I didn't uh put up I didn't talk
about yet but um
really appreciate you coming out and uh
you know I would be able to say support
Live Comedy I don't like that I don't
like when people say that yeah I don't
know how that became a thing you know
that how that became a thing people who
are like just down to go see comedy just
for comedy and not the people that they
necessarily want to go see but just
comedy like night oh comedy at like a
[__] Italian restaurant support live
comments when they say that uh but uh
you know yeah that is cool if you
support Live Comedy but also come to a
show christalia.com uh and then uh those
are all the new dates
uh that I'm that I got right now
um and it's been awesome man Boston I
didn't talk about this but Boston was
spectacular so much fun we did that
um uh nov in November 12th and we did
Albany dude Boston 6 100 tickets love
you all Boston did not talk about this
yet now before I went to Boston the
night before I went to Boston did
I try to wrestle Calvin yes did Calvin
[__] rise too quickly and try to get
away and smash the back of his head into
my jaw yes did it dislodge yes was the
paid excruciating yes did it hurt him at
all no and that's okay and then did he
say and then I go ow and then did he say
relaxed at it hey yes didn't make me mad
no because love would it make me mad if
anyone else told me to relax even though
I was just chilling yes it would but
Calvin did it and he's my heart so he
said Relax that and I said Kevin it's
gonna be okay was I sure about that no
thought I had to go to the hospital
because I thought they were gonna have
to reset my jaw now
my jaw it [__] hurts so much
uh I was like I'm just gonna ride it out
literally called the doctor because I
was gonna have to come dude I couldn't
close my mouth couldn't close my mouth
before Boston couldn't close my mouth so
I thought I was gonna have to go to the
hospital
but guess what he's got
a mouth guard
he's got a [__] mouth guard
oh he's got a mouth guard what's he got
it for he's got it for the last time he
had TMJ disorder still got the disorder
[__] up on his left side Calvin [__]
up the right side yes dude can't close
his mouth so the next day I woke up
still hurt took the flight
land oh no dude actually
yo American Airlines sup dude I [__]
straight up got a flight 2 p.m sup got
on the flight sup pilot
not with full disc doesn't do the full
disclosure thing to all the passengers I
get it because I panic but before so we
left the gate pilot comes on
all right so you know what we're this is
my [__] old manager yeah so look look
we're gonna be on the runway here we got
a uh minor mechanical issue we're just
gonna have the guys coming and it should
be fine we're gonna do that's a minor
accountable issue
okay cool chilling a few minutes go by
you're gonna have to go back to the gate
uh we're gonna go back to the gate and
we can see what's up man see what this
issue is all gonna be fine because even
if we have to switch planes whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa what's with what's this switch in
Planes talk
that minor mechanical issue so now what
have we done we've uncovered a liar as a
pilot right he knew all along
but what did we do dude see maybe we
didn't uncover a liar if he had to go
back to the gate and fix this minor I
give him that but hold up he's already
talking about maybe switching planes
hold up
we uncovered a lot dude we dug up
a liar
that's what we found dude right got
something here that's what we did and it
was a liar so we get there and we go
okay well maybe we're not gonna have to
[__] deplane whatever all good if we
got a new plane that's gonna be super
annoying but he said minor I'm still
holding on to that minor I'm holding on
to that minor mechanical issue that he
said I'm gonna just holding on to it
right because if it's minor maybe it's
an air vent or a [__] uh armchair you
know or uh uh uh what do you call it
what do you call these things the
[__] armrest
and a thing right because sometimes you
go on the plane and you see a guy
standing up a passenger you're like why
is he standing up and he's like mother
the seat belt isn't this and then the
guy with the yellow vest comes in and he
just yeah that's okay all you got to do
is throw you know unscrew the thing and
then there you go there's the seat belt
that's a minor issue so why are we going
back to the gate it's fine I'll let him
have it and I'm holding on to the miner
I'm holding on to the minor mechanical
issue so we get to the gate
I talked to the stewardess hey uh excuse
me do you know what's going on and she
says I'm literally the last person to to
ask about this I actually don't know she
was sweet as all you know very sweet
um and she was like I'm literally I
don't know I'm the LA I'm the worst
person to ask but you know it'll be all
fine it'll be good whatever so anyway
she walks away then
so we're gonna actually have to get off
the plane soon and get off the plane
we're gonna do get another plane we're
gonna get another plane for you uh we're
gonna we're not playing foreign
gotta get off the [__] plane I'm
pissed but it's all good right because
I'm with my team I'm not alone right so
I'm not a lonely boy I'm with a bunch of
team members and that's great all right
I'm with some of the people that are
opening for me I'm with my camera guy
I'm with my tour manager I'm with my
friend David Sullivan as well dude
it's very fun okay so I'm like all right
we get off the plane got caught up in
the court here for a second hold on get
off to the of the plane walked out they
said we got another plane showing up at
seven now you know if they say the plane
is showing up at seven it's showing up
at eight [__] yeah dude if they say a
plane's showing you know what we got
another plan actually it's gonna show up
at seven o'clock you know if it's not on
the schedule because it's not on the
schedule right it's coming in from New
York it'll be I walk I walk out I said
later on the desk so they said seven and
they said yeah seven oh dude already
when she did that yeah so it's gonna be
I go oh it's gonna be a
[Music]
don't sugarcoat it just tell me what's
up dude the pilot talked about it with
the [__] minor mechanical issue and
now all of a sudden we can't even be on
the goddamn plane dude it's gonna be a
so I'm like all right cool you know what
I got my team with me and we got five
hours to kill hey Hudson News here I
come
hey the latest issue of Shape magazine I
guess I'll pick you up for some reason
right hey Esquire nice cover with Ethan
[__] awk on it or some [__] you know
that's when you notice that [__]
oh I'll go get some icebreakers for some
reason oh and then some icebreakers
that's me in the airport when the
flight's delayed and then uh what is
that there the uh the I'll get the
winter green Altoids like I'm [__]
95.
and peanuts because I'm an elephant now
I'm at now I'm an elephant that my
flight's delayed
um and so
so we get on the plane now at eight
P.M
and it's the same stewardess and I'm
like whoa dude she's been here all day
and she's gonna fly through the night
and I don't even realize because of the
time difference by the way I don't like
people who don't realize time
differences right I I don't do that and
this is you know not something that's
like a totally this is not unforgivable
but like when somebody from the East
Coast calls you at six a.m and they're
it's like oh sorry it was nine I didn't
think about the time difference
dude what what are you doing with your
life that you don't understand that
there's a time difference when you call
somebody all the way across the country
you know
like that doesn't you don't think about
that so but I'll think about the time
this is and we're Landon in Boston at
4am dude we got to the airport at noon
we're Landing the next day at 4 00 a.m
[__] yeah my anger's Rising [__] yeah my
anger's Rising good job anchor hey anger
what you doing all the way up there well
I've got to be up here because it's
entirely too long to be traveling even
though the Fletcher does be five hours
hey anger when you coming down it'll be
a while
so
so now we're on the plane we land at 4am
we get to the hotel at 5 00 a.m and I go
to sleep and that is why you travel the
day before because I would have missed
both of my banging ass shows and 6100 of
you would have been sad as [__] and dude
let me tell you something man I put that
100 in there 6100 because I tell people
how many tickets I sell dude I found out
comedians be lying about their ticket
sales
for real that's crazy dude
we're all very fortunate to do what we
do for a living there's no reason to lie
about that
um so yeah I did the Boston shows and
man they were [__] unbelievable I
love Boston there man top whatever top
well definitely top five cities I mean
forget it but man might be my favorite
City to perform in dude these
[__] get it dude you could push
right I say don't push me but dude you
push you push a little Boston goes
they go [__] they cheat they cheer
dude we love Boston man you got to go
watch the tour report those [__]
shows were ridiculous
um met a lot of cool people at the meet
and greets uh uh and I appreciate all of
you man I really appreciate all of you
dude I really do you know
um
a lot of people talk because I talk a
little bit about my you know I talk
about mental health and [__] on stage
and I talk about it on my podcast and I
talk about you know my OCD and you guys
tell me that you know I do meet and
greets and sometimes you tell me you
suffer from the same [__] and
it's just nice I'm right there with you
dude I I it's unfortunate we got to be
in this situation but I'm right here
with you and uh and know that man know
that
um
then we went to Albany and that theater
was nice as [__] I've done Albany like
maybe four times and I was at this place
called the egg that's the theater that I
play in Albany and it was a thousand
seats and they were just great man
um
and it was like an evening you know
those Sunday night shows are very nice
they're I love Sunday shows dude I love
them
if you can get to a level where you sell
out Sunday shows it's the best because
you're like I did the rocking weekend
and now let me just [__] you know
have a chat with you guys and it feels
really great especially with that
theater because that theater was a very
like uh I say an evening out theater you
know it wasn't like a rock in theater or
a beautiful ornate theater it's just
like a nice kind of theater that they
put together no real character except
for the fact that it's you know in the
shape of an egg as they say
um but yeah it was great and uh we had a
really good time there in Albany or as
my camera guy would say Albany and then
I get pissed off and it's all good but
um yeah dude so uh the the the the the
Jaws better obviously uh but not all
better
and it hurts but it's better so that's
great Duty I'm telling you when when my
jaw unhinged I go I say oh okay man I go
right to Lifesaver
I go right to Life's over
you know
like I'll I'll hit my head and and me
are you like me dude you hit your head
and you go life so life's different now
life's gonna be different life's over
my my son hit my jaw I go great won't be
able to talk anymore the rest of my life
there's my money gone
I'll have to be the first [__] you
know
comedian doing sign language
I don't know man
I'm wearing the merch join our cult it's
awesome I love it look at that with the
way it's bunched up real nice on this
[__]
bunched up real nice on the wrist with
the watch keeping it at Bay dude just
keeping it at Bay look at that [__] man
the sleeve wants to creep on a come up
dude right but it can't the watch is
keeping it just keeping it at me the
right sleeves got a chance right my
creep on might go to the bottom of my
thumb but look at it all nice and
bunched up just to watch keeping it
stationary that's so [__] ill I swear
to God I like the best things dude and
look at the back of it
foreign
get that it makes a great holiday gift
go get that at crystallia.com we got the
purple life we got the Periwinkle life
rip shits we've got all the shits we've
got other [__] you know hoodies and
it's getting colder and the jacket which
goes
dummies I mean
great gifts you'll get them by Christmas
chrysalia.com we got the brown life rips
we got this set right here the hoodie
and the [__] ridiculous
so it's all good to make great gifts so
does uh gifting this patreon patreon.com
crystalia uh uh anyway dude
enough with the commercials but it's
bunched up real nice you know you gotta
have fashion man some people don't give
a [__] of a fashion right Steve Jobs
said it doesn't matter uh uh
uh a human is only programmed to make a
certain amount of snap decisions in a
day and if you're just wearing the same
thing then that means you could use that
decision for something else later on in
the day and you know what we say that to
say about that with Steve Jobs would go
like this no I don't believe in that
Steve Jobs because that sounds
absolutely ridiculous but that's what he
said and other people say that too but
your boy stays dripped out and he's
gonna keep the [__] join the he's
gonna keep the join the cult hoodie that
you can get at crystalleague.com all
bunched up and at Bay with his [__]
rolly it's absolutely it's fashion you
know I mean it's fine dude I don't go
overboard I'm just you know I like to
look nice
uh my wife is a gardener did you guys
know that she's a gardener she got a
[__] Gardener box and we put it
outside on the patio and she's got a
whole net so the Flies can't eat the
fruits and uh or vegetables and it you
know she'd been gardening she go out
there she put the seeds in she Waters it
every day we got a whole whole
um uh
um what do you call it hose up into the
thing it sprinkles the water in it gets
nice sunlight dude she's tried to do
gardening she was making cucumbers
carrots pumpkins Tomatoes
um uh asparagus you know all sorts of
[__] snap peas I don't even know dude
she had gummy bears coming out of one
and dude she was just planting [__] and
waiting for him to grow and dude she's
been doing it for months and finally I'm
like hey sup with those vegetables
because she's starting to cook more
she's making pork chops tonight and she
goes wanna see my carrots and I said
sure and she goes like this here they
are oh dude
oh dude
oh hey dude
looks like ear wax
oh dude
hey what are you doing hey you failed
look one fell I didn't even notice it
this is a carrot whoa and she's making
she cook it with carrots tonight and I
go well [__] man I better save my
appetite dude and she says wanna see my
cucumber and I said sure oh dude hey
what the [__] is this from what the the
the house that the little that the wife
put in hereditary the the little mini
house this this is the the [__] she's
a farmer oh dude look at this look at
this cucumber dude it's a surprise
calendar penis dude oh did you make a
new species of vegetable why has it got
warts on it
not only is it too small Scott warts on
it dude
Scott lortz that would be an evil
villain in a [__] 1950s Marvel comic
book
oh no it's Scott warts
dude what the [__] how do you grow a
cucumber for months and come out with
the size of a [__] fingernail
oh dude dude
how'd you do
it so anyway dude we're we're moving
we're straight up moving to Asheville
and we are going to farm
we're moving to Asheville and we're
gonna Farm that's it we're gonna have
little [__] vegetables we're gonna
call we're gonna call it little
vegetables Farms
and just the corn you won't even be able
to find it
like by the time you you take the corn
off the cob it'll be it'll be like lint
we'll need like magnifying glasses
dude this is a [__] honestly this is
a carrot
for real I'm not joking five months in
the making
and it's not even genetically engineered
that's hilarious looks like earwax um
so yeah uh so she's a farmer and we're
gonna you know that's what's up
just on incredible dude
speaking of Steve Jobs the uh did you
see the um
what do you call it
he they sold his uh worn out
Birkenstocks at an auction for 2 218
000 dollars
Steve Jobs
I mean
first of all Steve Jobs died like seven
years ago or when when did he die
well hey why are these still around
maybe four weeks later you give the
world a little bit of a process to mourn
and then get rid of the Birkenstocks but
when they die
2011 dude it's been 11 years and they're
just offloading there's Birkenstocks
oh yeah these dude they're probably not
even his probably some housekeeper that
was just like they're her husbands but
then they were like well we we want we
we clean for Mr jobs so we just sell
them for 2018 100 dude this is insane
2018 k
for Steve Jobs old Birkenstocks someone
bought him too
how much money how much money must you
have
to get Steve Jobs worn out Birkenstocks
billions right
it's got to be billions
like the only person who afford it is
Steve Jobs
dude he died 11 years ago
dude they got to start selling his other
[__] sell his turtlenecks sell his
glasses you know
what's going on
where are they gonna put this [__]
you're gonna frame him God that's
disgusting to have old Birkenstocks dude
Birkenstocks are so terrible
you know
uh some of them are banging but not
those I'll tell you that much
um I can't believe that they that they
did that that's great great well you
know what dude get that money
get that money whoever you are
uh can you click that one I can't click
it for some reason
the Steve Jobs one so I can no I did it
um and the jaw problems and the Boston
see this is how I do it and the trip to
Albany
can't do it great sounds great sounds
great
um now honestly that sounds great
did you see this thing
Chris Evans
I mean so okay so
Chris Evan let's watch this for a little
bit first this is People magazine got
flicks and chill boxer briefs
PDA
movie Patriots I haven't seen either
tough call I'm not gonna do it refuse
pass no pass
no ooh impossible not possible but I'll
say black widow Linda what idiot says I
is this guy just fingers so here all
right so he's he's saying there this is
People magazine and he they're doing
okay he's one of the sexiest men alive
which is okay you know I that's the
thing I don't like the most because it's
such a PR stunt they get the most I mean
he's a good looking dude but look at the
ugliest trog of the dice and they're
just like sexiest man alive just because
of like
uh and so he's answering all these
questions summer or fall I know fall
fall
oh
the other one
oh that's so tough no it's just that's
so tough it's okay dude it's like
picking between your children okay well
God that's so tough okay I gotta go Led
Zeppelin though wow damn that's a tough
one that's the hardest one so far
showers
comedy documentary
oh man
hero wow
clam chowder so wait did he say he
didn't even say so they posted this
thing uh and then somebody tweeted under
it
uh I guess he has a relationship with
this girl
like Brazilian person this Brazilian
her name's Alba something
I literally just found this out because
I saw this but somebody tweeted we are
team Evans we are disappointed we are
hurt okay so it's a long letter but this
is written to Chris uh Evans and I'm
going to by the way he's wearing a
v-neck sweater you know
um Chris Evans
um
as this is what it says Chris Chris
happens as a 30 year old first of all
too old too old to be writing a letter
like this okay as a 30 year old
[Laughter]
to it but we'll go
we'll go with it I've basically grown up
on your work from the hot jock to
Captain America to Lloyd Hansen who's
Lloyd Hansen I don't know uh it's been a
pleasure seeing your career grow and
transform but beyond this and what makes
you stand out from the crowd you've been
the most real and genuine person I've
watched in Hollywood dude how can you
say that
how can you say that
when there's people who like literally
get in trouble with what they're saying
with every week and Chris Evans you'll
be like how do you feel about milk and
he'll be like well I don't want to
offend orange juice but
uh you know it's it's great
you know
how can you say that
uh
uh your humility your love for your
family friends and Dodger I guess that's
a dog your sense of responsibility to
use your voice for good and so much more
I truly admire how you've never deviated
from your narrative over your 20 plus
years in the industry so when you speak
we listen we believe in it we believe in
you
this is why your fandom loves you and
why we are so loyal
up till now oh okay well what'd he do he
must have committed genocide right well
what did he do he must have
you know streaked out a soccer game
right like what happened
ah I'm hooked
this past week
it's like we won the lottery when you
finally got the title of sexiest man
alive finally okay it's a little
overboard I'd rather win the lottery but
Kay teach their own
as long as I've waited for it I actually
felt glad that you only received it now
because I believe that you are your best
right now and finally you are being
recognized I was so saddened when this
Pride lasted all two days
oh
he must have choked a bunch of puppies
here we go
I have to start by clearing this up your
Phantom is not upset because you're in a
relationship
where's it going
let's see rather it was the reveal of
your relationship that made us feel
betrayed by you we feel betrayed by the
Chris you let us to believe is you
don't ride it all good but wrap it up
okay write one of these things and then
don't send it have it be an exercise for
you
at this point I go like this
and this okay
now let's read the rest of it I didn't
think that so it's still a little bit
longer but as a human being I fully
believe that you deserve your privacy
and you will obviously only share what
you feel comfortable with great
Rubble good sincerely crazy person
during the TGM press tour I don't know
that's a new movie maybe TGM
TGM press store you were asked a
question that had nothing to do with
your romantic life you however chose to
answer it with regards to your romantic
life you volunteered this information
yes you didn't explicitly say you were
single but you sure did imply it
the clouds during your people interview
you once again implied you were single
the publication even reported that you
were realistically speaking this should
not have this should have no bearing in
our lives as fans however as your little
fandom when you speak we listen we
believe in it we believe in you the
sense of betrayal is not because you're
in a relationship it is the rude
awakening that our belief in you is
based on nothing but lies that you've
been selling us yes dude I'm on board
with this person she won me over or he I
don't know if you if you could volunteer
up lies about something so trivial what
about you is actually real it's like a
kid finding out Santa isn't real no it's
not you're 30. now not on board again
this may come across as completely
dramatic to most but I hope you realize
how influential you have been on our
lives your relationship is really not
our business keep saying it but you
don't mean it
I personally know nothing of Alba the
girl uh and we'll never know the
Dynamics of your relationship a side
note an average 41 year old man looking
to settle down start a family and have a
quiet life at home will most probably
not do so with a 25 year old woman at
the start of her career it is just an
indication of how you've unfortunately
contradicted yourself I could go on but
I'm going to leave it here oh
you dude this is the sixth paragraph you
went on my only hope is that this
message will somehow reach you and that
you will understand the impact you have
on the lives of your fans and how you
have hurt so many of us oh although I'm
sure you will choose to only see the
part that support you
hey man
this is an exercise for you
hey man this is an exercise for you
well that's hilarious some chick just
tagged her only fans on it afterwards
just to try and get some subs you know
it's like you're watching this you're
like oh it's hilarious oh
so I don't go on Twitter Man part of the
reason also because [__]
people I want to kill myself so um yeah
do it absolutely insane dude hey guy
check in
hey guy go to a place with white walls
uh all good if you see color around go
somewhere less colorful with only white
walls and people in lab coats and
check in
you know what I'm saying but I don't you
know mental health aside if there is
something wrong with you I feel for you
because I have mental health problems
too but I don't write letters to people
I don't know
well whatever we all have our [__] [__]
them
[__] [__] [__] Chris Evans should
never have done that dude
Christopher should never have done that
Chris Evans had no kid huh he's gotta
have some kid dude he's 41 dude he's got
to have some kids man that'll change his
life
does he have kids I have no idea I have
no I know nothing about Chris Evans
except I thought he had blonde hair and
he actually has brown hair which so
that's cool
oh dude this [__] killed me
bro this the pastor I want I want to be
a pastor after this
to his return and closer we get to him
the faster things are going to happen
the faster the healings the faster the
Deliverance
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a bee a b Flu Near him and then he did
that a bee flew near him
he is awesome and the closer we get to
him the faster things are going to
happen the faster therapy
[Applause]
dude that guy is a
menace behind the mic this guy dude this
guy is that when he
the best part is he couldn't control the
Holy Spirit within himself
at all and that's why he started
screaming but still had the wherewithal
to pull the mic away so we didn't
rupture the speakers dude the Holy
Spirit was in him but the Holy Spirit
also had the audience's back because
they couldn't be hearing that [__] dude
he pulled it out dude that [__] is
awesome I'm a pastor now I'm gonna be a
pastor that's so awesome and it is so
awesome that he's wearing a vest it's
unbelievable
wow that sucked you know I I they these
kinds but this guy is just
we are getting closer to his return and
the closer we get to him the noise the
level
s to the healings the faster the
Deliverance
[Applause]
dogs and dolphins were like trying to
get in after that I mean just so loud
God I love [__] like that but uh the
girl has a lot of tattoos who knew ah
um
yeah
unreal
see what this is all about
so important for a working dog to be
able to lock onto their target crochet
and do commands uppo while they are
fixated on it here but if I ask losing
his mind knock onto me he needs to stay
locked onto me until I ask him to lock
onto that Target help her loss is mine
here well he switches those visuals but
I also want him to be able to switch his
vocals a ball
you know
it's so important for a working dog to
be able to lock onto their targets dude
his mind just literally goes
wow but the build up isn't amazing to me
he needs to stay locked onto me until
that Target look helper
starting to lose his mind right there
right there starting to just kind of
like to that Target help her because it
kind of like lost touch with reality
right there a little bit those visuals
but I also want him to be able to switch
his vocals a ball
get up
foreign
[Laughter]
dude unbelievable that was a good one
wow that's unbelievable I'm gonna go
tell that to my dog he'll probably just
[__] on the couch and look at my eyes
while he does it um
dude you know speaks full English
without an accent trained his dog in
whatever the [__] language that is as
he's Bubba
wow that was a good lost your mind
that's a good segment here the lost your
mind segment that's an unbelievable that
was a great lost your mind
sending your lost your minds on my
Discord on patreon what says the dangers
of marijuana
uh
oops cut that up bleep that out
I haven't get rid of much incentive the
dangers of marijuana no dude
wow wow so high
oh my God bro that Wall's paper thing
wow he's in the next apartment
imagine being another side of that
oh he's so high dude
oh the other guy's so high
oh everyone here is the same look at
that one
oh my god I've never seen someone so
high
oh my God
I mean what is that [__]
candy on the side well everything about
this is so high you know the [__]
candy on the side laughing when he put
his head through a wall and wearing the
Patagonia
um dude
wow bro I would be [__] if that
happened in real life to me and I saw
that oh my God forget it
done so
absolutely done though absolutely danzo
I hate when they
do this
dude how about out because we talked
about Steve Jobs
we look about we look at the Steve Jobs
thing dude thank you for watching this
podcast I'm really grateful for you guys
like And subscribe dude wait they won't
keep us at [__] they keep us at six
at five sixty five Ninety Six dude what
the [__]
why can't we get to six six hundred
thousand dude something's up man I don't
like to believe in Shadow Banning but I
feel like they're Shadow Banning
first iPhone this is a day 2007.
I've been looking forward to for two and
a half years
dude so he made the first iPhone in 2007
and then died four years later
wow
the dorks in the audience every once in
a while
he's watching this [__] can't even
believe it that changes showing off
showing off the volume stuff
and
Apple has been
well first of all one's very fortunate
if you get to work on just one of these
in your career
Apple's been very fortunate
it's been able to change the whole
computer industry the 1984 computer and
look at the dorks clapping it's unreal
so boxy suboxie dude
in 2001. here we go watch the doors we
introduced the first iPod
oh they didn't really care for that yeah
oh wow okay
it didn't just change the way we all
listen to music it changed the entire
music industry yeah it did didn't it
well
today oh boy
oh we're introducing people are going to
do 10 of the dorks [__] here
three they did three
oh dude they're gonna just so the first
one
is a widescreen iPod with touch control
oh they love it they love it dude
and that that lasted one year nobody
ever got it ever again you know and they
loved it dude
just wait to the third one dude it's a
revolutionary mobile
oh oh dude dude the guy goes
yes dude did you hear that one guy
imagine doing that imagine do that for
anything dude hold up
the guy dude
imagine being next to that guy you'd be
like all right bro watch here we go we
gotta hear that again this is the guy
extreme inhalation second
is a revolutionary
[Applause]
I thought that would be the third one
what's the third one the third one is me
I'm a robot
[__] dude so many people are pissing
there and the third oh boy
is a breakthrough internet
communications device
look they don't know what that is
[Applause]
what's the third one widescreen iPod
with touch controls a revolutionary
mobile phone and a breakthrough internet
communications device
oh this is in the phone he said an iPod
got it
a phone they love it they're laughing
and an internet community so giddy and
it's all in one an iPod oh repetition
dude he's killing
are you getting it
yeah
three separate devices oh he goes one
device they go nuts
dude look at oh it just cut to somebody
goes a gift and we are calling it
iPhone
today apple is going to reinvent the
phone
and here it is oh no
no it's not that's silly come on
actually you don't even know that's a
joke leave it there for now
so
before we get into it
I mean let me put some like the
conantine maybe let me talk about a
category of things the most advanced
phones wow this is crazy bro that's
crazy That Changed History wow
why are the comments turned off I want
to see what people are saying about that
they just have like [__] somebody
saying subscribe to my only fans wow
dude
that is just incredible Steve Jobs and
then died four years later wow
um
do we have uh no these are not right
right skills
no these are new these look new
not wearing a seatbelt here we go
deserved scales
here we go
oh no it's just gonna be bad
um
[Music]
oh
no
how did he do that dude
oh my God the car just went oh my god
dude I mean dude
okay so this dude's just badass with
that big ass motor
just [__] look at him dude loves
country music and just how did the door
open dude
I mean you know shut the way he falls
out
is just so [__] up dude
like how Okay so he's overshoots his
shot right there
still he had Jorts on you know holy [__]
that must have hurt I hope he's okay wow
why how did he not
why does the door just fly open dude
somebody said because the car's a hunk
of junk from the distant past but
strangely permission
but how did the you have to open the
door for it to open dude
uh god well luckily it happened then
right when he died he thought his day
was going to be so good you know he's
like let's get out there and open road
man we're gonna go we're gonna get some
[__] hot dogs later it's gonna be fun
man and then just smashed
here we go
man what's up with people huh
and this guy's trying to get a coconut
here out of this van this whole thing
already so Asian by the way just the
first picture of it
trying to get a coconut standing on his
truck deserve its scale
I mean
you know
oh it's a woman
jacking It Off
oh he got what a dick dude he just
laughs wow I didn't know that coconut
was so [__] big let's see it hit her
head again so so it shows Judy what I
just said
dude worst reflex is known to man
wow dude
I mean yep
oh wow that's uh
wow somebody literally said third
comment is this comment section is
[__]
um
I guess you can uh die that way imagine
that's how you died from getting hit
with a [__] coconut on your head
um
there we go
here's another one
oh my I'm in the still frame of this
[__]
it's a [__] coming down the stairs with
the scooter
first guy did it oh wow this is gonna go
bad either spit
this asphalt came out oh
oh he's bleeding in the front of his
head or what I mean the guy's such a
dick dude TJ Miller
the first guy's so [__] wow that like I
really had good center of gravity though
TJ Miller dropped by this guy with the
light on the front of it you know
when one one step dude got one step and
then already
he got hurt oof that hurt oh [__] man so
dick
so dick the other guy
look and then takes a video of it look
so dick dude check your friend so dick
the guy's the worst breath the guy in
the bottom wow dude
unbelievable man
aren't you worried
why can't I click this one
I'll just open
um that was a deserve it if I've ever
seen one man don't roll the [__]
don't roll downstairs with a [__]
scooter you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
stops is good see that's a good friend
he stopped the video and went to go help
him look at this here look
is that what that thing is for
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh [__] that's a nine dude I feel like
like don't do those things you know man
like I know I know it's sad when people
get hurt but like
also it's not even that thrilling you're
just kind of up for a foot for a while
and then you slip and hurt yourself eh
so bad
wow
um
that's great
uh well okay that's good I'm gonna
[__] uh I'm done here you guys are
great
um I had a good time with you thank you
so much uh for listening subscribe to
the YouTube uh let's get those numbers
up and uh during the holidays yeah I
might not be doing over an hour during
the holidays for December and [__] you
know but uh but that's how I feel like
doing it I gotta [__] take some time
off somehow and I'm going going but uh I
appreciate you guys and then also uh get
tickets to Chrisley chrisley.com get
tickets to the Don't Push Me Tour I'm
gonna be in New York I'm gonna be in San
Diego I'm going to be in uh Portland and
Seattle and uh Brea California that's
not that's just a club date but go to
Chicago you gotta be in Chicago Tulsa
uh Midland Texas Sugarland Texas
um and Austin you know go to
christie.com and go get that merch it
makes for a good holiday gift look at
that one looking good nice and bunched
up the watch keeping it at bay that's it
for YouTube if you want to catch the
rest of the episode The uncut the raw
the uncensored episode go on over to our
patreon patreon.com
crystalia and you can watch the rest of
the episode and you can also watch the
uh one episode that the patreon members
get an extra episode a month that you
can check that out you can also gift the
patreon to somebody for the holiday
season appreciate you guys thank you so
much
have a good have a good have a good
night
[Music]